meanwhile u.s health officials warn the
rapid spread of the highly contagious
delta variant in parts of the midwest
could happen
in other parts of the country some areas
are now recommending masks and other
covert restrictions
to fight the spread and our nancy chen
is in hard hit
springfield missouri this morning nancy
here we go again good morning to you
good morning to you tony absolutely as
covet cases spike here in parts of the
state
we spoke with one mayor facing a
possible recall vote
some of his constituents want him out
for implementing public safety measures
mayor how has cobit affected your
community we've had a lot of cases
and hospitalizations and a few deaths in
our community so
it's been a hard year as the pandemic
hit nixon missouri mayor brian
steele tried to kirk kovan 19 from
spreading last year
including helping impose a masked
mandate nine months later
steele is facing a possible recall
election this fall
after dozens of constituents signed a
petition seeking
to remove him from office what's behind
the outrage
by some of these people and some of your
constituents to wearing masks
sometimes they say that it's because
damage the economy sometimes they say
it was because it wasn't done properly
both
those things aren't true the virus is
still a looming threat
in christian county where nyx is located
vaccination levels are more than half
the national
average as covet cases are spiking
emergency care centers near nixa like
mercy hospital springfield
are also stretched thin the hospital's
health system announced wednesday
it will be requiring staff to be fully
vaccinated by the end of september
or face possible termination local
officials are warning surges in their
state
could be dangerous for everyone the
people
that are admitted to our hospital now
97 percent of them are not vaccinated
the real concern is that you know if we
if we're seeing this high number of
delta variants here in southwest
missouri
why wouldn't we see it in other parts of
the state or in
other parts of the nation
and according to the kansas city star
health officials here in springfield say
the spike in cases started around
graduation season
and memorial day weekend as more people
started to gather vlad
nancy thank you very much